I mean this messy deal is crazy he
turned he turned down a billion dollars
from the Saudi government to go play in
the United States what does your dad
think of that
um
even though Messi's from Argentina if I
told my dad about that my dad would say
Messi's an American hero
for turning down the sound
um but I think at that I get it but I
think at that point it does it's not
about the money right I mean Messi has
more money he's free as you were saying
before Messi's free he's he's reached
Financial Freedom I would think there's
yeah there's a couple things with this
that I was talking to a buddy of mine
Who's involved in sports and he was like
a lot of times these athletes validate
themselves through the contract that
they get even if they don't need the
money right right and I and these these
contracts that you can get from Saudi or
some of these uh oil states are so
exorbitant it makes you feel in the
Twilight of your career that you're
still that dude and maybe that's why
Cristiano accepted it but what's really
interesting really the third thing that
we just spoke to that's what they're
doing yeah they need that yeah that's
exactly what that is but it's kind of
cool yeah now don't get me wrong this
deal and you probably know the
intricacies of the deal mark But like
this deal is also very lucrative because
he could get what like pieces in a pile
yeah so he basically like the American
royal family basically like the
corporations that exist within America
stepped up to basically match or beat
the deal right
so Apple has all the streaming rights
for the MLS and they said hey messy if
you come over we'll give you a piece of
the stream and he deserves it because
that's the only reason we're gonna watch
Adidas says hey you're coming over we're
going to give you a piece of all the
shoes that we sell with your name on all
the all the soccer all the jersey sales
for the MLS he gets a piece of oh no
okay wait so check this this is so
interesting so I am like uh outside of
being the number one you know football
journalist in the world I'm also quite a
casual fan of football but I said to
Emma on the way home yesterday we're in
some Uber and I was like hey do you know
who Lionel Messi is and she's like oh
yeah yeah the soccer player and I'm like
well he's going to play for this team in
Miami would you want to go like see a
game when he comes to play in New York
and she's like that would be awesome
let's go do it that's why you pay him
yeah yeah the casual and the even more
casual barely even aware of what the
sport is yeah are like I need to go see
this guy I want to go I've never watched
an MLS Match in my life
if they come well I'm sure they will
come to New York corporations unite and
they find a way to pay him as much yeah
I could be a real guy I think he's able
to purchase a team eventually for like
the same time
no messy sort of gets a similar deal
when he finishes I assume the president
wants it set like that was a big thing
yeah I've seen air yes at the end of the
movie uh how real this part is I don't
know but as they're about to close the
deal Michael Jordan's mom was like oh
there's clearly some oversight in the
contract you guys forgot to mention that
we would get a percentage of all the
shoes he sells and the reason Nike was
like really like [__] is this set to
precedent and now this is just what dude
do you know Jordan only made 93 million
dollars in his career but is worth 5
billion today yeah so talk about that
Roi in what it so I mean 93 million is
insane but you really people need to
give credit to Michael Jordan's business
because I know he makes 400 million a
year off the sneakers
93 in his whole career yes and keep in
mind the last contract he signed I think
was like a 36 million dollar a year
contract remember Jerry Stackhouse was
like aren't I worth a third of Jordan
there's no remember Jerry stack yeah
yeah yeah and uh and he was like aren't
I worth a third and now 12 million we
look at the contract yeah Jerry was
worth 12 million but back in the day
you're like what 12 million the highest
played player in the [__] illegal no
no that he really is like you might
Brian Moore you know Brian Morton he's
the one that sent me that yesterday
shout out Brian Warren AKA Lancelot he's
got this dude this guy's got you've
never seen a midi this guy's got a
haircut like a medieval Knight yes but
he rocks he looks good and and and so he
sent me that article and I was like whoa
dude like people like why is it he not
why is he he should be the one on Shark
Tank yeah like he should be the one
because he's not taking anybody's deal
yeah he's gonna [__] deal yeah make them
feel bad tell them get the [__] out of
the road yeah no yeah did you see the
Magic Johnson thing so in the 80s he was
offered a deal with Nike and they were
like Hey we're gonna give you a
percentage we're gonna have your shoe
blah blah and then he was also given a
deal from Converse at the time there
were two separate companies and the
conference deal was basically like a
hundred thousand annually or some [__]
and Magic Johnson was like Justin at the
beginning of his career and he took the
converse deal for a hundred thousand a
year annually instead of the Nike deal
which now would have been points in Nike
oh yeah
was this reasoning did you say his
reasoning was this was more popular at
the time Converse was more popular he's
like I didn't have any money I was like
a kid just playing in the league so I
had to take the guaranteed money and I
couldn't bet on this like fledge okay he
got drafted what the late 70s Jordan was
84 and even then when Jordan got drafted
Nike was nothing for basketball yeah so
imagine even bearing for that yeah yeah
but that deal now would have been worth
like three billion yeah like something
crazy and he talks about he's like [__]
I really it's so funny because magic
business-wise yeah he did yeah he's a
billionaire two problems yeah but in the
moment he made the right choice if you
look at all his [__] but in in hindsight
that Equity deal is like crazy but
that's what you yeah yeah I heard Kevin
Hart say I think on the Logan Paul
podcast work try as much as Ken's work
with companies not for companies and I
feel like that's that's that mindset
that makes you super rich is when you're
just we're all in this together give me
a piece I'll take less money up front
but let me you know Bank on you know
that's what Warren Buffett does Warren
Buffett's just like banking on the co on
the companies that he thinks are going
to go the furthest he's like give me a
piece and then you know become you
become uh rich like that everybody wins
yeah yeah you need to have a certain
amount of like Financial stability to
take that chance and Cloud to even allow
you to allow them to even allow you to
do that so it's easier said than done